amanda ruiz méndez estamos en el mes de
la herencia hispana en quebec y en
algunos otros lugares de canadá y de
allí que estamos interesados en hablar
del servicio en español de radio canadá
internacional con artistas y con
personas en general provenientes de
hispanoamérica y que recién aquí en
canadá y ese es tu caso tú eres un
artista que reside en la ciudad de
montreal y entre el material que
consultado sobre tu trayectoria se dice
que tú eres un artista que explora las
versiones oficiales de los fenómenos
sociopolíticos y los convierte en arte
de qué manera
sí bueno la perspectiva que normalmente
yo uso la metodología es que todos los
proyectos que yo elaboro primero hago
una investigación así que la mayoría de
mi trabajo es tiene como dos lados uno
que es como investigación y el otro es
como materializar esa investigación
entonces la mayoría de mi trabajo está
basado en eso
y lo que me interesa mucho es
el lado que normalmente se hace público
sea por algún medio de comunicación
alguna literatura
que se hace de distintos fenómenos
sociales políticos sociales sea un
movimiento revolucionario o el feminismo
o si diferentes este movimientos
sociales que bueno en el caso es la
mayoría son sobre méxico y lo que hago
es como desdoblar un poco esa parte
oficial y tratar de ver la parte como no
oficial lo que quizá no está en un
registro fotográfico o este o textual
y digamos que yo me
me meto me fugó un poco en esa parte y a
partir de ese lado como no oficial como
que intentó detonar ciertas ficciones o
modelos alternativos para
para continuar con el tema político pero
quizás con un brazo como mucho más
ligado al activismo entonces por lo
tanto siempre la propuesta artística
siempre tiene como ese brazo de
investigación pero también incorporó
mucho el lado activista que es este
espacio en donde
pues ya mí me acción individual quizás
ya no es tan relevante como en el tema
material o de investigación sino es más
bien el tema que yo pongo como en como
donde yo me enfoco es un escenario mucho
más social mucho más maleable del cual
yo no tengo un control
pero con el cual yo siempre estoy
intercambiando dialogando este
para crear como todas estas situaciones
que puede ser un performance
participativo pero también puede ser una
instalación puede ser un fanzine
entonces dependiendo del proyecto yo
siempre intento como buscar nuevos
medios como para hacer esa triangulación
entre digamos mi experiencia personal la
experiencia social como en general
y esta otra experiencia como muy oficial
muy bien marcada en
bajo ciertos rigores formales y bueno
ahí es donde mi práctica se
se mueve todo el tiempo y además de la
técnica de la performance y las otras
que nombraste y de qué materiales te
vales para realizar tus obras
la mayoría de la
de mis trabajos tienen una presencia
importante de textiles
de lo que acá en canadá hablan como
fibras que es este papel y textiles todo
material que está elaborado a través de
fibras
este entonces la mayoría de mis
proyectos siempre tienen como un
elemento textil y eso viene como de una
es una admiración y un interés también
de investigación por los textiles
mexicanos indígenas mexicanos
y también por una fascinación por
por el lenguaje textil
a través también de la moda como que
para mí es como estos paisajes urbanos
que están siempre cambiando y que son
parte de la identidad de una ciudad o de
un lugar bueno viene un poco de ahí y
también de
de mi experiencia también un poco en el
teatro como diseñadora de vestuario
entonces es un poco como si diferentes
escenas y escalas pero el el material
que
que por lo general yo uso en el cual me
siento un poco más cómoda son los
textiles nombraste a mexico y en tu obra
la iconografía y el imaginario la
impronta del arte mexicano sigue
presente a pesar de que tú estás
radicada aquí sí claro si sigue porque
bueno es algo que yo de lo que yo me he
alimentado toda mi vida entonces digamos
que ya tengo como un vocabulario visual
así como un vocabulario al que yo
siempre recurro
y más lo que me puedo alimentar de
investigaciones personales de viajes de
colaboraciones con algunos artesanos
entonces bueno si ese es ese puente con
méxico sigue muy muy activo y se va
transformando y evolucionando con el
tiempo y si hay un puente porque hay una
distancia porque hay dos puntos para
unir tú estás aquí en canadá porque qué
es lo que te trajo qué es lo que te sacó
de que de méjico y te trajo aquí a
canadá
si yo vine hace 7 años a montreal y vine
a estudiar una maestría en concordia en
la universidad de concordia entonces yo
estudié este firebirds al material
practices que es como el nombre oficial
es una maestría entonces bueno me viene
acaba un poco por eso también temas
personales de relación y este y con el
tiempo pues me fui creando y bueno ahora
ya estoy más este
tratando de establecer un poco en los
dos lugares espero lograrlo porque ya
tengo como muchas relaciones y
y cosas que ya me unen a montreal y a la
vez también en méxico entonces bueno
siempre está está como batalla interna
entre dos o más lugares esto de
estabilizarlos y los lugares que decir
que reparte si el tiempo entre un lugar
y otro entre méxico y canadá pues se
intentó no siempre logró este ahora con
el tema cobit pues tengo que regresar
como a méxico
de manera indefinida porque me
perdí mi estatus migratorio y este
entonces no tengo como mucha opción más
que salir del país y empezar a tramitar
como otro otro estatus migratorio pero
estando fuera entonces bueno pero aún
así sigo como manteniendo proyectos de
trabajo o colaboraciones con colegas y
con grupos sociales aquí en montreal
porque yo tengo toda la intención de
continuar porque son proyectos y
relaciones de muchos años que pues
tienen que encontrar un nuevo cauce pero
que siguen ahí no hablas de estatus
migratorio y precisamente en tu obra hay
presencia de la situación de los
llamados sin papeles aquí en canadá
además de tu caso personal la situación
de otras personas en esa situación es en
ese caso te preocupa
sí claro más que una
una preocupación es una ocupación este
llevo colaborando ya varios años con el
centro de trabajadores migrantes del cti
aquí en montreal
y hemos podido hacer como una muy buena
mancuerna de colaboración especialmente
trabajo con colaboró con el grupo de
mujeres de atap que es una asociación de
trabajadores migrantes que han sido como
estafados por las agencias de empleo y
que por una u otra razón llegaron con
papeles y perdieron como su estatus por
diferentes este
violencia administrativa o burocrática
sea privada o gubernamental en muchos de
los casos entonces bueno es algo que
con lo que me he involucrado mucho en
este tiempo viviendo acá
y sobre todo con el grupo de mujeres en
específico que son todas trabajador la
mayoría de trabajadoras domésticas
trabajadoras agrícolas temporales
y del sector también textil y crees que
esta sociedad la sociedad que ve la
sociedad canadiense en general la
sociedad de acogida de esos migrantes
les brinda todo el apoyo necesario
pues no la verdad que no digamos que hay
una cantidad importante de población
migrante que está sin papeles
y qué
pues que viven condiciones de
precariedad absoluta
muchos son muchas de ellas llegaron
pidiendo refugio o como trabajadores
temporales y se quedaron como en un
limbo administrativo en donde también
ellos establecen relaciones aquí de
trabajo personales este de amistad con
con diferentes personas y bueno se
acaban quedando pero en una situación
bastante
precaria donde no hay un acceso
a servicios médicos donde el abuso de
los jefes o patrones hacia empleados sin
papeles es como la nuevo hermano siempre
ante la amenaza de si no haces esto si
no haces aquello pues yo llamo a la
policía para que este deporte entonces
es una es una situación que aunque tiene
guarda sus diferencias con estados
unidos quizás nosotros somos más
conscientes de la situación eeuu por por
cantidad
son millones y millones de personas que
viven indocumentadas
quizá acá es menos pero lo que se vive
es realmente trágico y
y no no se toma como con la seriedad que
debería tomarse la situación de los
trabajadores agrícolas es literalmente
de esclavitud moderna y son todos los
trabajadores que vienen de centroamérica
de áfrica de méxico por supuesto y que
se enfrentan a una especie como de
secuestro laboral donde son explotados
este
en unas condiciones bastante denigrantes
y inhumanas y todavía no se considera
eso como un tráfico de personas
como una actividad criminal todavía no
se sigue hablando como de no bueno es un
patrón en que es un jefe una granja en
específico la que ha tenido como mal
tiene un mal historial no laboral pero
ya cuando te vas a detalle pues te das
cuenta que no es una ni son dos sino que
son muchas y que es la norma de la
explotación porque claro para una para
un trabajador guatemalteco hondureño
mexicano pues ganar 13 dólares la hora
es mucho para ellos entonces también es
una
una situación de pues aprovecharse de
las condiciones de miseria y de guerra
que tiene es al menos esa parte del
continente americano méxico y
centroamérica
traer mano de obra esclava completamente
entonces
la sociedad quebequense realmente no es
consciente de lo que está comiendo y de
dónde vienen todos estos productos
a la mesa y que nos comemos diario sean
bio
novillo o lo que hay atrás de también
método esa mercadotecnia
que si es biológico orgánico no sé qué
pues hay mucho de esa explotación
laboral
amanda y luego decíamos al comienzo de
nuestra conversación y está de alguna
manera emparentado con este tema también
este octubre es el mes de la herencia
hispana en quebec canadá existe tal
herencia
pues no sé si pueda hablar de una
herencia como específica que tenga que
ver con el lenguaje que sea una herencia
exclusiva del español
quizás lo que hay es una herencia
latinoamericana
claro porque ya son varias generaciones
de emigrantes que han llegado a
establecerse muchos pues que ya han
tenido hijos aquí que son que es que
quédense eso latino quebequenses
entonces más que hablar de una herencia
hispana porque ahí estaríamos
quitando a brasil haití esta parte del
caribe las guyanas
son latinoamérica
y si creo que más que una cuestión del
lenguaje
una complejidad cultural que nos
hermanan también pero es verdad que no
todos hablan el español incluso
estaríamos
eliminando a toda esta población
indígena que solo habla una lengua
indígena y que probablemente emigró
y empezó a hablar otra lengua como el
francés no entonces creo que sería más
bien una herencia latinoamericana sin
duda qué
el idioma español se identifica con
latinoamérica pero creo que hay mucho
más
qué son lo que un idioma y una historia
compartida hay una historia de
colonización pero también una historia
de resistencia y de movimientos
revolucionarios justo en contra de esta
homogeneización de
de este concepto de somos como hispanos
si como que a mucha gente todo este es
como pues no españa sí fue un imperio
que invadió que colo colo colo colo ni
son las tierras
pero lo que había antes y lo que sigue
existiendo pues está ahí entonces si
volvemos a repetir este esquema de
veis hispanoparlantes pues ya como que
estamos aplanando el territorio a una
cuestión como monolingüe que por
supuesto que no existen
amanda ruiz méndez muchas gracias por
esta entrevista concluyó que nada
internacional
muchas gracias a ti